okay a lot of people holding at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 let's hear from a few more of
them we're gonna go next to our caller
from the seven-four-zero area code who's
calling today from 7 4 0 hey David how
you doing good who's this hey my name is
Rodriguez um he was fan yourself man
truly is the honor to talk to you right
now thank you
I was just calling because this is I was
just calling because it's uh never
really concerns me I know most
progressive obviously support and Bernie
Sanders I don't know that that's true I
mean Bernie has roughly 20 low twenties
support right now in the Democratic
primary so unless you believe that there
are very few actual progressives voting
in the primary which maybe you do but I
mean it I don't I don't think most
progressives at this point are
supporting Bernie they're not not based
on the polling right ok ok well let's
say there's been let's say a large
portion of progressives are got support
now sure let's say that he does not
let's say that I said he's not going to
win the nomination do you think we could
see a repeat of 2015 where a lot of
those voters don't vote for the Democrat
nominee if it's not Bernie what evidence
do you have that a lot of Democratic
primary voters voted for someone other
than Hillary Clinton
no there's many progressives no they're
saying a lot of stuff they were not vote
for Hillary they couldn't vote for a
hurry to say no for nothing and many of
them have have omitted that he we're not
going to vote for Hillary
no there were definitely a large portion
of his of Bernie's base that deficit to
support Hillary many I'll stay home or
worse they'd vote for Donald Trump yeah
so there's no question that that
happened anecdotally but you are going
back and forth between saying some
people said it online and a large
portion did I have seen no evidence that
a large portion of Bernie supporters
stayed home or voted for Trump
everything happened anecdotally there's
people who voted for Trump in the
primary in the Republican primary
and ended up voting for Hillary for
example like anecdotally it happened but
I just I just think you're making a
bunch of assertions that aren't really
backed by any data I've seen I'm not
arguing with understand it they were
apportioned that that's know them that
didn't go for people that didn't vote
for our army Hillary I'm saying though
do you think there will be any of them
that wouldn't vote for the nominee here
let's say Bernie did win or 2009 the
primary certainly certainly there are
there are some people who are going to
vote in the 2020 primary and their
candidate won't win and they'll choose
not to vote in the 2020 general election
or to vote for Donald Trump of course
there will be some I think it's not many
I don't think it was many in 2016 and I
think given what we now understand to be
the overwhelming importance of removing
Donald Trump from office I think
whatever percentage there was in 2016
that did that will be even smaller in
2020 okay I hope you're right because I
know anything is better than this crown
is in the office right now sure but
thank you for our answer my question on
that I appreciate it all right Rodriguez
great to hear from you hope to hear from
you again